I just wanted to update you on some
things that have happened slowly that
you might not have noticed airplanes
today when they leave the runway
typically take off at a steeper angle
into the air than they once did many
decades ago what that does is reduce the
acoustic footprint of the airport so
that the sound is not disrupting
whatever's going on on the ground the
engines are more powerful to enable that
not only that the engines are quieter
than they ever were when I grew up if a
plane flew overhead you had to stop your
conversation let the plane continue
flying and then you continued your
conversation you cannot speak over the
sound of the engines now are you sure
you didn't grow up next door to an
airport
because that could have been the problem
foreign
[Music]